je rêve il ya une faute
bougez pas je vais arranger ça voilà
c'est mieux mais qu'est ce qu'il ya là
dedans
allez on efface tout et on recommence
depuis le début dans l'atelier
[Musique]
commençons par l'entrée elle est
essentiellement constituée d'eau dans
laquelle on a ajouté un pigment pour le
donner de la couleur en l'occurrence un
pigment bleu
alors des pigments il en existe de
toutes les couleurs ou presque en
général et se présente sous forme de
poudre
aujourd'hui la plupart et fabriqués à
partir de produits dérivés du pétrole
mais à l'origine les fabricants de
couleur utiliser des matières premières
naturelles il ya par exemple le noir de
fumée utilisé pour fabriquer de l'encré
de chine obtenu en broyant du charbon de
bois et les autres qui proviennent de
terre naturellement coloré le blue
outre-mer est obtenue en broyant de
lapis lazuli une pierre précieuse à
l'époque ce pigment valait plus cher que
l'or parfois les coloristes ont de
drôles l'idée il utilise des matières
premières auquel je suis sûr vous
n'auriez pas pensé
le rouge carmin par exemple est obtenue
en broyant des insectes les cochenilles
et le jaune indien à partir d'un produit
fourni par la vache son urine lancre
bleus effaçable est fabriqué à partir
d'un pigment qu'on appelle le bleu
dannielynn cette molécule a été mise au
point au 19e siècle
sa couleur est dû à la façon dont elle
réagit avec la lumière petit éclairage
la lumière émise par le soleil vous le
savez peut-être déjà est constitué d'un
large spectre de couleurs les fameuses
couleurs de l'arc-en-ciel souvenez vous
je vous en ai parlé lorsque j'ai
fabriqué un arc en ciel dans le jardin
lorsqu'elle arrive sur la molécule qui
composent le pigment bleu
la lumière est entièrement absorbé à
l'exception du bleu qui est renvoyée
vers nos yeux voilà pourquoi cette encre
nous apparaît bleu pour les encres rouge
ou verte le principe est exactement le
même
sauf que les pigments renvoie le rouge
ou le verre contenu dans le spectre
je sais je vous en fait voir de toutes
les couleurs et ça ne nous dit toujours
pas comment l'effaceur c'est disparaître
l'encré bleue j'y vienne l'encré bleue
on l'habille est essentiellement
constituée d'eau des molécule h2o et des
pigments go permet en fait de
transporter les pigments une fois sur le
papier elle s'évapore
[Musique]
les pigments eux restent accrochés aux
fibres de papier et se lie avec elle et
oui en principe on attend d'une encre
quel saint prime bien et qu'elles soient
visibles pour délivrer correctement le
message
le revers de la médaille c'est qu'une
fois déposés sur le papier l'encré ne
peut plus être retiré un possible de
briser les liens qui se sont établis
entre les molécules qui constitue le
pigment est celle du papier
c'est dire si la tâche est rude pour les
chasseurs
facile mais il a une botte secrète
suivez-moi sa botte secrète
c'est le produit qu'il contient du
bisulfite de sodium et de l'eau quand il
entre en contact avec lancre une
réaction chimique se produit l'aniline
ne disparaît pas mais à structure change
du coup elle ne réagit plus de la même
manière à la lumière désormais toutes
les couleurs latraverse et atteignent le
papier l'aniline devient invisible et
c'est le blanc du papier qui est
renvoyée vers nos yeux de m mais je vais
vous montrer quelque chose
jusqu'à présent j'ai effacé des lettres
mais on peut aussi rendre visible un
message qui n'était pas un message
secret par exemple durant les deux
dernières guerres c'était le grand jeu
des espions tenez vous voyez cette
feuille elle a l'air parfaitement vierge
et pourtant elle porte un message on ne
voit pas parce que je les écris avec du
jus de citron pour le rendre visible
il suffit de passer la feuille au dessus
de la flamme d'une bougie
attention comment je peux avec le feu
cette expérience nécessite père
hâtivement la présence d'un adulte
admob c'est parti
et voilà en fait au contact de la
chaleur les sucres contenus dans le jus
de citron caramélise et le message
apparaît alors je sais c'est la fin de
cette vidéo est pas la peine de vous
faire un sang d'encre
on se retrouve dans une quinzaine de
jours et d'ici là bonne rentrée le noir
de fumée est utilisée pour faire de
lancre déchets la plupart se présentent
aux la plupart la plupart un tout qui va
pas en train de me demander parce que si
on a du vent tout à l'heure et ce qu'il
faudrait pas que je mette un foulard